Let's go through an example of a repeated measures design, where every
participant gets both treatments. These are two cell phones with different
keyboard configurations. Let's say a researcher is interested in the effects of
these cell phone configurations on errors made in typing text messages. To
study this, 25 participants used each keyboard type. This is QWERTY since it
spells Q-W-E-R-T-Y in the upper left and an alphabetical keyboard. And they
typed a standardized 20 word text message within 30 seconds. The number of
errors for each person using each type of keyboard was recorded. These
participants were randomly assigned to which type they used first. In the
Google spreadsheet below, you'll find the data for the number of errors each
person made using each type of keyboard. Find the mean number of errors for the
QWERTY keyboard and for the alphabetical keyboard.